Happy birthday
oh and uh for me as well feliz universal
beiges beiges in honor of your
natal day i'm going to magazines double
fisted on operation thunderbolts
i hope we get some meet each other
again
hope you have a fantastic day we
love you man happy birthday uncle james
happy birthday i look up to you
a birthday suit and a birthday toot
james happy birthday james i love you
man i'll be in lots and lots of cake i'm
going to smoke
the cigar in your honor hey james happy
birthday here's to more years of more
crazy
if you think that's bad you should see
my underwear i hope you get a really
delicious
poke bowl thanks for uh you know making
my dreams come true i hope you have a
great day very surprised you're
still celebrating things like this given
your age
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my new suicide squad
first look teaser breakdown there's a
bunch of big stuff coming up with dc
fandom as well they'll be dropping a
bunch of big dc
trailers so be sure to subscribe to get
all those videos of course i'll be doing
videos for all that stuff
what they're doing in this is just
showing off all the main characters
confirming john cena as well i know
there have been a bunch of jokes about
him being in the previous teasers but
you just can't see him because he's john
cena so i'll explain what's going on
with this
they also teased a really big rock
steady
superman teaser with suicide squad in
his head here i'll explain what's going
on with that too
i'll start with the suicide squad movie
stuff then i'll talk about that superman
teaser at the end of the video
since this teaser is all about just
showing off the main characters and
hyping up the big dc fandom panel i'll
explain who these characters
are some of them we know a little bit
more about than others there's still a
couple mystery characters
also explain where this new movie fits
in the timeline and how it's connected
to the first suicide
squad movie because it's not a
full-blown reboot but they are sort of
reimagining what the suicide squad
movies look like through james gunn
that's why they're calling the movie the
suicide squad and not suicide squad two
this is the official logo of the movie
they don't include all the big
characters in this teaser but this is
most of the main cast of the film there
are a bunch of other side characters too
and a bunch of big comic book easter
eggs like peter capaldi
is in the movie as a mystery character
everybody thought that he was mr freeze
but because of what matt reeves is doing
with the new batman trilogy with robert
pattinson i think there are a couple big
batman villains that are off limits so
i'll talk about that during the video
you see harley quinn herself opened the
video this is meant to take place after
the events of the birds of prey movie
it's not necessarily connected to what's
going on during that even though it does
take place in the same universe because
the birds of prey movie involves
characters from the first suicide squad
film
in the first suicide squad film is kind
of connected to the second suicide
squad film is a very loose continuity we
have a look of her on set she's walking
around in the red dress from the comics
so just an alternate look from harley
quinn that what you saw during birds of
prey and during that first suicide squad
film
and even though jared leto's joker still
exists within this version of the dc
universe he does not appear during this
movie it's not like he's coming back
because obviously he's off in the marvel
sony spider-man universe doing the
morbius movie right now
but he did say that there's no version
of the joker that appears during this
movie is
just harley quinn so she might reference
stuff that happened with the joker in
the events of the previous film but he's
not going to appear on screen as far as
we know
there's been a lot of talk about a new
version of the joker appearing during
matt reeves batman trilogy with robert
pattinson
but that would be a completely different
version of the character and he'd have
to recast him
and there is no joker that's supposed to
appear on screen during the first new
batman movie
but obviously you see that rick flag is
back from the first movie you also see
the captain boomerang
is back from the first movie just
confirming that they aren't completely
wiping the slate clean with that first
suicide squad film
i know because of the big justice league
snyder cut movement and the fact we're
getting that movie next year
people are starting to turn to david
ayer and wondering if he's ever going to do
an air cut of the suicide squad movie
but because they have this new james
gunn version of a suicide squad movie
coming out i don't think they're going
to do anything with david ayers suicide
squad cut
you finally see idris elba show up most
people believe that he's bronze tiger
idris elba was going to be will smith's
replacement in the movie
initially they talked about recasting
him as a new version of deadshot but
then just because they didn't want to
step on will smith's toes too much and
pissed off too many of the fans they
just decided to turn idris elba into a
completely different character
there was a whole lot of bronze tiger on
the arrow tv show during season two
and fun easter egg here for the batman
franchise at least the dark knight
christopher nolan batman franchise but
the bronze tiger of that tv show was
actually played by michael jai
white who was also one of the gangsters
during the dark knight so just fun
connection between all the big dc movies
especially big batman movies in the tv
shows
obviously we have to talk about john
cena's character we finally see him show
up in a suicide squad promo
but he's playing peacemaker peacemaker
is just a
really really hardcore punisher level
character
in the dc universe the joke about his
character is that he loves peace
so much he'd kill for it you don't see
him till a little bit later in this
promo but this is steve agee he's
supposed to be playing a version of king
shark so there will be a couple of big
motion capture characters in the movie
like they did killer croc during the
first suicide squad film
the closest we've ever come to live
action king sharks so far
is actually through the flash tv show
they've been using in the past couple of
seasons
taika watiti is also supposed to be in
the movie even though he's not in this
promo but because he does so much
korg and motion capture in the marvel
universe i'm also expecting him to be
another motion capture character during
the suicide squad film
you recognize this woman as alice braga
from the new mutants movie she plays
celia reyes an x-men character so it is
funny to see an
x-men character from the mcu show up in
a dc movie so
soon if we ever get to see that movie
there were a lot of people last week
that thought that she might be playing a
version of poison ivy secretly in the dc
eu because we've never seen a version of
poison ivy in any of the newer movies
james gunn debunked that so it's
possible that poison ivy doesn't show up
until the new matt
reeves batman movies because she is a
bigger batman villain
alice braga could be playing a version
of black orchid but is still open to
theory crafting black orchid
is a justice league dark character who's
kind of a plant-based hybrid kind of
like poison ivy
discount poison ivy basically you all
probably recognize pete davison's
character he's playing
savant just a relatively minor suicide
squad character that gets killed off
pretty quickly during the new 52 i don't
know how big he's going to be
during this movie this is meling ing
she's actually playing the female
mon gal mongols daughter even though
she's not in costume here you see what
she kind of looks like with her makeup
on in these set photos
nathan fillion's character is still a
bit of a mystery a lot of people think
that he's blackguard from the comics
relatively minor character
it really doesn't matter so much who
he's playing it's going to be a super
obscure super weird character from the
looks of his costume
but nathan fillion is always fantastic
in whatever he does so i'm just really
excited to see him actually show up on
screen in a james gun movie he's had a
couple cameos during the guardians of
the galaxy marvel movies
but the first one was a motion capture
alien so you didn't get to see his face
and a secret cameo during guardians of
the galaxy 2 wound up getting cut for
time so he didn't make it into that
version of the movie
you all probably recognize david
doshmalian from the marvel universe he's
in all the ant-man movies he's playing
polka dot
man obviously super obscure super weird
character
it'd be like condiment king from the
batman comics showing up in a dc movie
you probably recognize storm reed she's
playing a version of idris elba's
daughter in the movie
you all recognize james gunn's brother
sean gunn who shows up in all of his
movies
often his motion capture characters he's
playing a version of weasel from the
comics
then this girl is daniella melchior
she's playing a version of rat catcher
just another hardcore really obscure
super weird character
if you don't recognize this guy this is
flulaborg he's a comedy youtuber who's
actually started to do movies the last
couple of years he's playing a character
called
javelin from the comics you see what his
costume looks like it is suitably
ridiculous that's why he's acting so
ridiculous during this
he mostly plays characters that are just
really really comedic and over the top
michael rooker obviously very big during
that first look teaser of the cast we
don't know who he's playing either
long time james gun collaborator
typically plays
really hardcore characters so i would
just expect something in that tone but
the way james gunn talks about it he's
going to be dropping
at least some sort of teaser at dc
fandom the way that james gunn has
talked about it in the past
is that they're kind of treating it like
a funny tongue-in-cheek joke
about the whole nature of the suicide
squad comics and task force x
the whole concept that the team itself
is expendable
amanda waller does not give a crap about
any of them
i'm hoping james gunn really reaches for
that joke and in the first 10 minutes of
the film
he winds up introducing a crazy version
of the team that he then
kills off then they form the actual
version of the team that you see for
most of the movie
the whole thing with that superman
teaser this morning that rocksteady
posted on their account is for the brand
new
suicide squad arkham style game that
they're making the reason why the
suicide squad target is painted on
superman's head is because there are a
lot of rumors that it's actually a
suicide squad
versus the justice league game like in
the game you are the suicide squad and
you're supposed to take down the justice
league
there'll be at least a couple movie
trailers and teasers i don't know how
many they're going to be releasing but
i'll try to do videos for everything
so as long as you have alerts enabled
for my channel you should see all those
videos when i post them
while you wait for all that stuff click
here for that brand new wonder woman
trailer and click here for that brand
new boys season 2 trailer
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!